Captain's Log, Star Gate 22 31 57.6.
We are en route to the planet Regulate 5, sector 18,...
...to deliver a vaccine to end ultraviolet fever.
Captain, we're picking up something on the long-range sensors.
Spek, what is it?
Unknown, Captain. It's unlike anything we've ever seen.
Bring up the view screen! It's too distant to make out.
The brightness, the energy. Whoa!
Captain.
What is it, Lieutenant Orula?
I'm receiving a transmission from a Klingie ship.
The Klingie's have a saying, Captain,...
..."If you cannot control yourself, you cannot command others."
He looks like he's beaming aboard.
Mr. Scootie, how much time do you require to repair the warp drive?
Four bloody nanoseconds! But it's Happy Hour down here in the engineering room!
I'd rather beam up a tribulator, if it's all the same to you.
Shields up! Go to red alert!
Aye aye, Captain!
It's too late, Captain.
Typical Federation, not to have your defenses ready.
What do you want from us?
Only your certain doom!